[Musique]
l'egypte y ont gagné la course à la
terre d'abord ils l'ont repeintes pour
que ça fasse plus gai maintenant ils
vont l'inaugurer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il inaugurait la terre pendant des
années et des années
c'était facile parce que quand il avait
fini d'inaugurer eh bien ils repeignait
tout d'une autre couleur et il
recommence et pendant tout ce temps là
les malheureux shadoks tourner en rond
dans l'espace parce que eux la terre il
ne l'avait toujours pas trouvé ou bien
quand il tombait sur une aile et fo
alors à force d'aider lamentablement de
fo se tait en faut se taire à la fin
qu'on aime il finir par tomber sur la
vraie alors des nuages de shadocks
menaçons envahir la terre le ciel
s'obscurcit la fête de la terre était
fini léger bear entre elles il y avait
du shadow play
il en tomba il en tomba il en tomba
apens donc 40 jours et presque autant de
nuits la plupart en tombant heureusement
ce cas c'est alors ils virent bien que
c'était pas avec des shadoks comme ça
qu'on pouvait conquérir la terre et
qu'il fallait en fabriquer des neufs et
plus vite que ça
[Musique]